[Music]
watching
other people lose their minds can be
very
entertaining
so entertaining in fact that people will
often
goad their favorite streamer into
blowing up like a volcano
uh 200 meters behind that
and then i get and then i get a whole
stream sniper squad that kills me
and dude it's so annoying man
[Music]
he's not even looking at me have you
come in here and say [ __ ] you and
your friends to [ __ ] me bro you can
go [ __ ] yourself
but before it became fashionable to be
angry to scream our lungs out and act
like savages in front of
thousands of onlookers there was a more
restrained rage monger that walked among
us going by the name
of greg idra fields
a quietly brooding starcraft legend who
in a world of many supposed [ __ ]
simply had none to give you're kind of
notorious
for being a little bit bad manner um and
and me knowing you personally i would
say that's
that might be based on some truth a
player who spat in the face of tradition
and took the concept of competitive
rivalry in esports
to a whole new level what do you think
about cruncher and how do you think this
match is gonna go
i'm playing really bad but it's more
than enough to beat him so
whatever happened to this bad mannered
esports
pioneer and what legacy has he left
behind for those who came after
here is someone that you either love to
love or love to hate
i mean i was known for being a bit of a
dick that was kind of my thing
now when you hear the name idra i'm sure
that unsportsmanlike conduct is what
springs to mind
but the truth is his signature
unfiltered disdain
is only one piece of a complex puzzle
you see
underneath idra's harsh exterior is a
man deeply concerned with promoting
international relations
and understanding you're actually from
canada right from toronto toronto
how do you feel about dating a
non-citizen
it is my goal to get a green card it's
this is a green card marriage
a man with a keen sense of fashion and
with me
we do have the one the only the gracken
in his leather gracket it is idra and
a very particular sense of humor he has
like three or four different openings
like phoenix
uh robo expand uh twilight expand
and uh then he goes into this the exact
same timing at uh
at the exact same time so maybe should
watch out for that right
that's fascinating yeah anyway as one of
the best western starcraft players out
there
idra always stood out in more ways than
one
he began his pro career during the brood
war era
after he won astros starcraft superstars
tour
he packed his bags and moved to korea to
play
starcraft for a living and being one of
very few non-korean players in seoul
made idra an instantly recognizable
figure
in-game he was widely known for his
macro abilities
more specifically the art of playing the
long game
and amassing more resources than his
opponent the longer you let idra play
the more powerful he got if you imagine
like he was trying to reach over 9
000 status every single game the
strategy made him a
fearsome player to face off against and
back in 2009
it brought him victory in nearly every
non-korean tournament
in the world however after making the
switch to starcraft 2 in 2010
and moving back to the states in 2011
idra found
success harder to come by mostly due to
his
well inability to adapt if someone
wasn't playing
properly cheesed or went all in on the
early game
idra made sure they knew they messed up
rather than own up to
any shortcomings he had the game is way
harder for zerg and zerg has way less
tools and injured ggs by saying
you're a joke this guy's awesome but
this guy's
pretty bad and this guy's just terrible
that guy was trash this guy's really bad
he's actually chatting he's like the
reason there's no zergs on the server is
oh
goodness i guess they are not friends
after all and here we go
and mask you are saying i am honored sir
to receive
hydra rage hydra here is going to leave
the game
and congratulates his opponent as well
what an interesting uh
choice of words there from both players
i i thought at first they were good
friends but apparently
worst enemies in disguise and idra
didn't just deploy his trash talk in
matches either
even outside of the game he showed his
opponents
no mercy we just saw zerg bond qualify
what are your thoughts about that
about me qualifying or zergbone he won
you qualified what are you gonna do
i'm gonna win this time so we have a
good winner this time all right guys
well
shake hands if you're going to
[Music]
idra do you have any words for your
opponent m.c
[Applause]
now to anyone observing idra's antics
from the outside
he looked like a menace but in the world
of starcraft
his behavior was especially egregious
you see the competitive scene in korea
was founded on a long-standing tradition
of
mutual respect you humbly accepted
victory
just as you stoically swallowed defeat
would you put some pressure to happen
some words describe him
he's an opponent
he says flashes of god mutual respect is
touching
the respect is real according to kespa
if you wanted to surrender a match you
were expected to say
gg and exit gracefully failure to comply
wasn't just seen as disrespectful it was
also potentially
punishable and idra wasn't exactly big
on showing
anyone respect so as you can imagine his
opponents took his behavior towards them
pretty personally they really dislike
the lack of respect
which is funny because they take any
opportunity to be disrespectful
themselves like the moment i say
anything to them they flip out
and like everyone lists me as their
rival and gsl and stuff so they're a
bunch of hypocrites
but yeah they don't really like me as
far as i know so it's safe to say that
the way that idra carried himself became
something of a trademark and his
attitude didn't just manifest itself in
the form of
insults either you see if idra thought
he was about to lose
whether or not that was actually the
case he would just
rage quit we're having technical issues
i don't know what happened
oh greg you're just i'm disconnecting
your rage quitting from this too
one of the most famous instances of this
happened in game two of a series between
idra
and his long time rival huck at mlg
dallas 2011
a game that idra lost because he thought
he was about to get his ass handed to
him
except he wasn't the void raise all
hallucinations doing
absolutely no damage whatsoever there's
the blink up onto the high ground just
trying to distract idra
those hallucinated void rays almost
fully charged wheat
and idra left the game
oh oh my
goodness a little bit of a blunder there
by idra not actually playing it out to
the very end losing to hallucinated void
race
huck was quick to let idra know he made
a mistake by quitting their
match and idra reacted exactly how you'd
expect
so huck can't win in a real game huh
pretty much you wouldn't win at all if
you didn't play projects
stand by your guns on that one and if
you thought that unfortunate encounter
might have taught idra a valuable lesson
well
baneling's getting absolutely
obliterated by these tanks but the
mutualist count is just
a little bit too high injury now
streaming forward with zerglings mutas
everything is overrunning the sports by
mma
what
[Applause]
did idra just leave another one game
that is absolutely appalling what a
what a disappointing way to begin a
series with a one game
we i am absolutely speechless so instead
of playing it out which is what you're
supposed to do
he gave the emotional response just
leave doesn't even bother to fight
oh aj oh it's funny in what had become
his typical fashion
idra continued to lash out against
things that ground his gears
but people's patience was starting to
wear thin
in march of 2013 while playing against
cap watch
idra made some rather unsavory comments
that turned him into an
even bigger villain within the scene and
while nothing really came of that
particular
incident a few months later evil
geniuses was
forced to act against their renegade
rager after he offered some rather
unkind words to his fanbase idra's
inability to control himself
had finally come at a cost like an hour
ago
i learned that idra was released from
evil geniuses it's brutal to hear
because
i mean i know greg and he's i would
describe him as on the quiet side in
real life and very giggly at the end of
the day there are
serious consequences you are always
responsible for the consequences of
whatever behavior you choose
as fate would have it idra's last game
as a pro starcraft 2 player
ended with him quitting well played here
by paul while killing off most of these
paintings yes he does lose a lot of
hellions but
uh now it also means that era doesn't
have enough failings to blow up most of
these
well no this is probably the
the least successful attack
yeah after years of falling short of his
competitive expectations
idra had fallen out of love with
starcraft and it wasn't just the state
of the game that he was growing tired of
but the so-called
fans who were only there to watch him
fail
i am not going to continue as a
competitive player um
it's just gotten to the point where
competition is not enjoyable for me
anymore and that is what kind of drove
me in programming especially in
starcraft 2. i don't particularly enjoy
the game
but i really liked beating people and
now that's just well i'm not winning
nearly as much which is part of the
reason it's less fun
but the competition itself just is not
as interesting to me or challenging to
me
or satisfying to me as it used to be and
without that i see no reason to continue
playing
after announcing his retirement from
competitive starcraft 2
idra focused on casting and even had a
brief stint on eg
as part of their heroes of the storm
team but following the starcraft 20th
anniversary event in 2018
he stepped away from the public eye for
good i think there's a lot of people
who immediately were like yeah good
riddance right those the individuals
that sort of like love to hate
idra um and then probably two months
later posted like i miss idra
so even though he's been gone from the
competitive scene for years now
why is it that people still look back
fondly on idris legacy
well in a scene that was often
criticized for being emotionally sterile
he was a
fierce competitor who unapologetically
wore his heart on his sleeve
and despite idra's dark reputation
underneath it all there was a genuine
person who just really wanted to win and
wasn't afraid to show his true feelings
when he didn't
if your only exposure to greg
was his games his streams and what
articles people wrote about him you
would think he was always like that
but it definitely was a part of
his persona that he did build and create
over
time you know starting all the way back
at brood war but when you were just
hanging out with him
you know it wasn't like he was this doom
and gloom indra that walked around and
hated everything but the truth is that
idra's
fiery disposition is the very thing that
made an
already incredible story that much
spicier
his penchant for tilting off the face of
the earth made him
more compelling for fans to watch and
strangely
that's what endeared him to them despite
his best efforts at being
unlovable i've had people ask me for
hugs that was a little bit strange
during an era over saturated with nice
guys
idra laid the groundwork for the esports
villains of today
to truly shine he was one of the first
competitors to recognize that
for fans it wasn't just about
captivating moments
in game but unforgettable ones outside
of the game too
when i think of greg edra fields the
player
and the human being i think of an angry
guy
didn't go to college no work experience
receding hairline
greg you know one of the most incredible
sort of stories someone from the us
playing
starcraft in korea during the brood war
area that
like holy [ __ ] that's that's amazing
when i imagine in 30 years and hopefully
my grandkids are like reading books
about esports like i think idris is
going to be one of this
one of the subjects of of chapter or
book or a legacy that that it that
exists one day
[Applause]
devin jones is the idra of the score
esports
oh god damn it [ __ ] you devon is like
one millisecond away from just
just putting his fist through his
monitor at like any
any given moment it might be valerian
all day long oh god
one under god damn it under